Whether you're saying tomatoes or tomatoes, it's clear that your accent is a hallmark
For your personality. Everyone has their own tone so goats have different ways of saying the word "Bawawah"
But what is the opinion of science about language acquisition and does your dialect say something about you?
In a poll in America, 47% of adults found they had high-end British dialects, while
51% of New York dialect was slut. Southern accents were considered nice accents but were
Uneducated, while dialects in Britain were considered a function of intelligence. But it turns out
Humans have a tendency toward others who look like them or have the same tone. Definitely,
It is important to distinguish between native language and acquired language
Native English accents depend on factors such as geographic location
Social and economic situation. For example the London dialect of the working class in London is different
Remarkably speaking of the rich class.
However, when it comes to non-mother language dialects (acquired) things become more complicated
If you decide to move to Spain and learn Spanish and your native language is English, you will always speak
An English accent - even if you stay there for decades. After the age of 12
The length of stay does not affect your accent. Studies accurately determine the ideal age
Is 6 years, with decreasing capacity from that point.
Interestingly, some stroke patients wake up with a completely different tone for the original acoustic tone
This condition is known as "foreign tone syndrome" you get as a result of damage
In a specific area of ​​the brain which is responsible for language processing.
An integral part of the language is the "functional vocal unit", which is a different voice message
They are used to form words, some of which are distinct for different languages. For example, the audio units are in
The word "TH" is pronounced in the form of "y" or "w" as in the word 'the' and 'thing'. They do not exist in German
Making it difficult for German speakers to pronounce these words correctly. On the contrary
There are many "audio units" in other languages ​​as in English speakers we can not pronounce or even hear correctly
In a pilot study conducted on 32 Americans and 32 Japanese children aged six months
Where they listened to the recording of a voice for "no no no" is repeated many times and when the registration changed to "la la ra"
The toy next to the kids will light up and play a musical tune. They were the children's pampers
To understand this and distinguish the difference between "No" and "Ra" results from audio and visual equivalent
The children studied by the two countries (America and Japan) were able to differentiate
The flash predicted the game but "No" and "Ra" are audio units
It does not exist in Japanese. When this study was carried out with children aged 10-12 months
Japanese children did not know the difference between this unique difference
English vocal units show that the critical age in the identification and development of the brain
Is usually for the 6 month period
If you are trying to learn a particular language, no matter how old you are, tangled threads are made
This increases gray matter density and strengthens white matter networks. In fact
People who grew up in a bilingual family are always more sensitive to mastery
Linguistic differences compared to their monolingual counterparts. Tests have been shown on Edema
Bilingual children found stronger brain responses in the macular and frontal cortex
Areas associated with concentration and problem-solving
But have you ever wondered why so many people hate their voice when they hear it?
We will destroy science and challenge some people to come out with their recorded voice
For your home you can see it through the link in the description below
Subscribe to more weekly scientific videos